Oh my god.
My name is Cat and my pronouns are she
her.
Thank you for being here with us today.
Whether it's your first time or your
first time in a long time, we're glad
you chose to be with us today. I have a
couple of announcements. First of all,
if you are anxious about being in a
worship setting, we have a a little area
over there that has some fidget spinners
and some coloring sheets and some noise
counseling cancelling earphones. If
you'd like to to use any of those, you
can pick them up on your way in and drop
them off on your way out. Our next state
of the table
uh meeting will be Sunday se 20
September 21st at 4:00 here. That's
before service. I hope to to
you join us then and we talk about our
ministries and uh the things that we've
been going on for the last few months.
Also, there is a welcome to the table
class on September 28. If you are
interested in learning more about this
community and please join us for welcome
to the table class, you can scan the QR
code and sign up for that.
Tonight is the first Sunday, so we have
a Hack Creek night. Jared is our host.
>> Hat Creek Burger Company is uh right
down 78 between here and WY on the
right. Uh we hope that you will join us
as a community for fellowship and and
eating some good burgers.
These candles are a sign of the presence
of Christ among us.
Fully divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and grace.
Now we enter sacred space,
a space for prayer,
worship and adoration,
a space to encounter Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
>> Thanks, Cat. If you guys want to stand
with us, we're going to start out with
some music tonight. Um, and I just
wanted to read from Psalm 32. It says,
"Therefore, let everyone who is godly
pray to you while you may be found.
Surely when the mighty waters rise, they
will not reach you. You are my hiding
place. You will protect me from trouble
and surround me with songs of
deliverance. And I hope that tonight as
we worship together that these songs
would be like songs of deliverance that
surround us, that remind us of God's
goodness and protection. So you guys
sing along with us if you would like or
soak it in. Um but we're so glad that
you're here to worship with us.
[Music]
Sing. Be still my soul.
Be still my soul.
Be still and know that my God is here.
[Music]
Be still my soul.
Be still and know my God is here. All
that I need to know is this. You are a
good God. The maker of heaven calls me
in. You are a good God and your heart
beats in my chest. You are a good God.
All that I have to do is rest. You are a
good God.
Sing. I won't be afraid. I won't be
afraid.
I won't be afraid.
I won't be afraid. My God is here. He'll
make a way. He will make a way.
He will make a way.
He will make a way. My God is here. All
that I need to know is this. You are a
good God. The maker of heaven calls me
head. You are a good God and your heart
beats in my chest. You are a good God.
All that I have to do is rest. You are a
good God.
[Music]
You gave me your eyes. You gave me your
heart. Your spirit flows through my
veins. You gave me your eyes. You gave
me your heart. Your spirit flows through
my veins. You gave me your eyes. You
gave me your heart. Your spirit flows
through my veins. You gave me your
right. You gave me your heart. Your
spirit flows through my veins. And you
gave me your right. You gave me your
heart. I had a right from the start. And
I know who I am. Cuz I know who you are.
You are a good God. All that I need to
know is this.
[Music]
The maker of heaven calls me heaven.
All that I need to know is that you are
a good God. The maker of heaven calls
me. You are a good God and your heart
beats in my chest. You are a good God.
All that I have to do is pray. You are a
good God. Yes, you are a good God. You
are a good God. You are a good God. You
are a good God.
All right, kiddos. Y'all are dismissed
to go to your classes. Your teachers
will meet you over there by the doors.
[Music]
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people.
Feel free to follow along on the screens
um and read aloud the parts in red.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
Johnny,
Adam,
the parents who lost their kids,
teachers,
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts. We pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence.
Amen.
[Music]
The love of God
is great and far.
or
[Music]
it goes beyond
the high star
and reaches
the lowest.
a guilty
bow down with care.
God gave his son
to
[Music]
his child.
be reconciled
and pardoned from
his.
Oh love of God,
how rich and pure,
how measureless
[Music]
and strong.
It shall forever
more endure.
The saints
[Music]
When there is a time
shall pass away
[Music]
and earthy Thrones
and kingdoms fall.
who hear
refuse to pray.
On rocks and hills
and mountains,
God's love so sure.
All measureless
and strong
redeeming grace
to Adam's race
the saints
[Music]
could with
the o
and were the sky
were every
on earth
and everyone
by trad.
[Music]
above
would the ocean.
Nor could the scroll
contain the
stretch from sky
to sky.
Oh love of God,
how rich and pure,
how measureless
[Music]
and strong
it shall forever
endure
the saints and
song.
[Music]
I want to know you know
I know
you know
[Music]
you
I want to know you more.
I'm laying down.
All my
Want to know you.
I'm laying down.
All my religion
I lay it down.
Want to know you.
[Music]
I used to think
I could box you.
I now
I want to know you.
I used to think
that I could watch you.
I'm laying down.
I want to know you, Lord.
Want to know you, Lord.
[Music]
Lord, I've been told
to be ashamed.
don't measure up.
Lord, I've been told
not good enough.
You're here with me.
Reach out and you
and I die.
Say no.
[Music]
I reach out.
You
find me in the
[Music]
singer.
Oh,
I reach out to you
in the dark.
[Music]
Swing your mouth.
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
in you, Lord.
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
in you, Lord.
I'll be shouting
in the simple by
in you.
I will reach you now.
[Music]
I always
give you
I
you
[Music]
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
in you, Lord.
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
in you, Lord. Lord.
Oh,
in you Lord.
[Music]
God, we do rejoice in your goodness.
We rejoice that you're close to the
brokenhearted.
We rejoice that you're on the side of
the widow and the orphan,
God, that you pull us up out of the pit.
We rejoice, God, that you're quick to
listen and quick to forgive.
[Music]
We rejoice that you are a good God full
of mercy and grace.
That you don't leave us where we're at,
God, but that you're always calling us
forward, pulling us towards more of your
love and your light,
towards life and wholeness.
[Music]
God, would we follow that pole?
God, would your current guide us? Would
it ground us?
[Music]
We love you.
We're grateful for this time together.
We're grateful to spend time with you.
And we just ask, God, that you would
open our hearts, open our minds to hear
what you have for us. your voice, your
words, your hope.
God, would it ring true in our hearts
tonight
in Jesus name. Amen.
Thank you guys for worshiping with us.
If you want to turn to the person on the
side of you and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you."
Oh, grace and peace.
It is uh it's good good to be with you
all to welcome you into this space. My
name is Brett and I'm pastor here and um
yeah, as always, I also want to include
those joining us online. You're not
forgotten. Love y'all lots and uh
especially anyone who's new here or just
still kind of, you know, visiting and
making your way into the community.
We're yeah, really, really glad that
you're here and uh we know especially
depending on church backgrounds and
things, it can just take a lot of
courage to to be here with us. So, um we
hope we're not too scary, but uh yeah,
we hope you do feel a sense of welcome.
So, we are in the fourth and final uh
part in our series titled Cultivating
Calm, staying centered in difficult
times. And uh I don't know I mean maybe
this series is like always applicable to
some degree sort of like always
difficult time you know but I don't know
it's something it's it's it feels more
uh prevalent now and uh I think this was
just a particular season of of some of
that for many of us and and there's you
know plenty going on in the world. I've
spoken in in recent weeks, you know, you
can kind of pick your thing from like
culture, whether the, you know,
continued persecution of the LGBTQ
community, kind of really not just
persecution, like scapegoating,
basically political scapegoating. And uh
that's obviously just been horrendous
and really difficult in particular for
trans people and uh and many of you know
here among us like not just some
theoretical group out there like this
is, you know, this is us. So you've got
that sort of stress and then uh kind of
economic job stuff. I know a number of
folks have you know lost jobs,
struggling to find work. There's just
kind of economic you know things. Then
you got sort of looming out there the
dark clouds of like AI whatever like who
knows whatever that's going to be you
know and just it's it's kind of a lot.
So that's like at the social level and
then of course there's just the personal
you know I mean we're just going through
stuff. We got folks grieving loss and
relational breakdown and struggle and
you know just stress and uh mental
health challenges and financial challen
kind of thing. So in that kind of
context,
what we kind of wanted to do is look
turn to Christ to uh into the Christian
scriptures to kind of look for some
wisdom and perspective on, you know, how
what might it look like to cultivate
some spirit of calm, the the peace of
Christ, you know, which we just finished
telling each one another. And but it's
easy to say, you know, oh, the peace of
Christ be with you. It's it's like a
different thing to kind of live into
that and kind of learn to ground
yourself and root yourself, you know, in
that. So that's kind of what the the
series is about is trying to press into
some of that. So because of that, it's
been sort of a like a at the
intersection of like sort of psychology
and and Christian theology has sort of
been the series and that'll continue in
this um in this message tonight. I will
say next week we're jumping into a new
series which will be very different. Uh
it's it's about scripture and uh you
say, "Well, we're always talking about
scripture." Well, it's sort of, you
know, a little bit zoomed out. It's not
like just focusing on scriptures, but
it's it's sort of what is scripture?
What what is that? and what is the Bible
and how do we approach it and and work
with it and you know all that. So it'll
be a little more I don't know
theological and um all that. So it'll be
a little change of pace next week but um
for now we're kind of continuing in this
vein we've we've been in at least for
one more week. So the title of my
message tonight is you can be made new
and our scripture is Ephesians 4 uh
verses 17- 24 that we're not going to
read the whole thing. This will be kind
of one of those messages where I kind of
you know walk us down through it. And so
we'll start with just verses 17 uh
through 19 which reads this is the
apostle Paul. Um oh also I should
mention just for context. So this is
Paul writing to the church in Ephesus
right that's the book of Ephesians and
this is a gentile i.e. you know
non-Jewish audience who he's writing to.
So this is you know you can think of it
like a lot of people very new new to all
this new to Christian faith and
following Jesus. And you can tell from
the context folks are
struggling there. There's um various
kind of compulsions and possibly
addictions and uh just things they're
going through. So that's kind of the,
you know, the context of this. So all
right, verse 17. So I tell you this and
insist on it in the Lord. You must no
longer live as the Gentiles do. In the
futility of their thinking, they're
darkened in their understanding. They're
separated from the life of God because
of notice not the hatred of God towards
them. He's so angry. He said I'm have
nothing to do with you. It's not that,
but actually it's the ignorance that is
in them due to the hardening of their
hearts. Right? So there's a kind of
distancing we can do from God. I think
God's always present, always seeking,
always wooing, always calling, beckoning
us, but you know, we're can we get in
different places. Some seasons we're
like, yes. And then some seasons we're
like, I don't even know about you. You
know, so um yeah, we go through
different types of context and things.
Uh verse 19, they having lost all
sensitivity,
they've given themselves over to
sensuality so as to indulge in every
kind of impurity and they're full of
greed. So I want to set this up with a a
quote from the uh a really wonderful
neuroscychologist named Dr. Julia
Danchi. I quoted her a few it was maybe
a month or two back but um she said
this. She said, "You've got to start
understanding you have only one problem,
and that problem is your relationship to
the energy of fear."
Which is interesting. This probably
would have been a great quote for week
one of this series, which was all about
fear. Um, but unfortunat
I mean, as a neuroscychologist, she's
not necessarily trying to like fuse this
with a lot of spirituality stuff. She
means it quite literally in terms of the
the kind of neurochemical processes and
it manifests as like literal energy and
such. So she means that in a more
technical scientific sense, not
necessarily in like a woo sense. Um,
also she said you could replace the word
fear with, you know, pick your preferred
word, you know, stress, anxiety.
Uh, I think it's sort of a filler word
for we've at times in the series called
it emotional dysregulation. You know
that feeling. You know, the feeling when
you're all worked up and and it's it's
different. You know, at times it's kind
of a a fear kind of light thing. At
other times it's sort of an anger and
you know, but you're just you can tell
you're the opposite of what we mean by
centered, you know, like I like that
word centered because it kind of speaks
to like almost a bodily sense you have
when you're kind of
rooted to the ground at home in the
world and in your body and present. you
know there's kind of a center where you
can get in that place and then we can be
in the other place you know so that's
what this is you have only one problem
and it's the other place the other mode
we get in and she it's not in this quote
but she talks a lot she says we often
get lost in situational specifics you
know well they said this and that and
then this did that thing and then they
did that and you wouldn't believe how
you know what I mean and you wouldn't
believe what I'm going through or this
happened and it's like yeah not like
that doesn't matter. But in the end, the
reason we're like, "This is so bad," is
because of what it's doing to our
nervous system. You know what I mean?
Like in essence, even if all that was
going on, but in the midst of it, we
felt like
calm, centered, you know, well, then it
wouldn't be so much of a problem. You
know, because in essence, the problem is
the feelings. That's precisely the the
it's that dysregulation that that kind
of gets us. And so, kind of what I want
to name is we get in that mode. we feel
it and you know by golly I'm right with
you. I hate it. Freaking hate it. I'll
like do anything to change that. I just
don't want to feel that that mode. You
know what I mean? And
this of course is where we get into
trouble because we start finding I mean
even quite young we start figuring out
ways to deal with that. You know at
times we can find really healthy or at
least reasonably healthy out outlets.
You know what I mean? going for a run.
You know, this is sort of very common in
like the uh sort of a addiction
community that they'll sort of someone
will, you know, maybe be struck with
alcohol and then they'll get super into
running, but not like you're thinking,
you know what I mean? Like, oh, running,
but like running 20 miles a day, you
know what I mean? Like really, but it's
it's sort of trying to replace, you
know, one incredibly destructive thing
with something. It still looks a little
over the top, but you know what I It's
it's it's a step in the right direction
trying to like okay how can I you know
kind of modulate and self soo in such in
in better and better ways and uh but of
course you know mostly we tend not to
turn to running or something you know or
prayer we we tend to uh I mean in a lot
of ways we're like we're all sort of the
same you know I don't know about you but
I like to think of myself as like a
really unique person but when I look at
how I deal with my own emotional
dysregulation I'm pretty much like the
same as anyone
you know, and uh it's it's there that we
we can kind of get into trouble. So,
this is where we come to verse 19. And
uh Paul, he uses there's two words we're
going to focus on tonight. The first is
sensuality.
And uh this is a translation of the
English of the Greek word asa, which
honestly the words the translation
sensuality is maybe a little I don't
know, a little gentle. the the idea of a
Selgea is like sort of a combination of
like sexuality with a bit of like um
taking advantage of or even a little
coercion. Not necessarily quite it's not
the word for like rape, but it's just
it's a sort of use using sexuality in in
ways that can be hurtful to oneself and
others. Um and so that's kind of what
what uh Aselg is getting at. I think you
know this could be a kind of pornography
addiction that's like taking us to very
you know dark places. Um it could be
adultery. It could be you know just any
sort of use of sexuality where it's not
building a kind of beautiful you know
intimacy with another uh but is uh kind
of using people you know and you say
well using it how well that kind of
brings us back to to our initial initial
quote from Dr. to Gangji right where we
have only one problem and it's this this
great fear it's this great anxiety it's
this dysregulation and the ways the
unhealthy ways we you know cope with
that and of course you know one of these
ways is this kind of uh sexual you know
acting out uh we could call it because I
mean in essence because it works like in
a sense of it does it brings temporary
relief if it didn't no one would do
that. You know what I mean? Like of
course it works kind of. But it's that
kind of that uh that that gets us. And I
I think maybe I could sum it up like
this. The root problem we might say of
like sexual kind of compulsions and such
um is not sex per sake, but the
unhealthy use of sex to manage my
negative emotions and feelings, right?
And I think this is where even we could
read or hear passages like this. I kind
of wondered how it hit you as I read it.
You know, it can just sound very, I
don't know, like classic Bible, you
know, sensuality,
you know, you know, this kind of finger
wagging like I don't know. But I I I
think this is really the heart of what
Paul's getting at. I really don't think
generally speaking that there are
passages that can be like this way, but
generally speaking, I think a lot of the
scriptures actually aren't like antisex
or something, you know what I mean? Or
anti- the body. I mean, if anything,
Judaism, the Old Testament kind of fed
into Christianity was actually quite pro
the body, um, as compared to certain
other religious traditions at that time.
So, uh, but I do think Paul has these
the types of concerns we're naming
tonight. I think that's a lot of where
he's, uh, he's coming from. In other
words, he's looking at the his church,
his gentile, you know, church, and he
sees where this is like messing up
people's lives, you know, and he's he's
speaking to, uh, to address that. Uh,
one way to think of this, I I think of
like using sex in this way. It's a bit
like scratching poison ivy. Any fellow
poison ivy sufferers out there? Like I
swear I'm one of those people like I
maybe this isn't a real thing. I feel
like I don't have to touch poison ivy to
get it. Is anyone like this? like where
it's like I was in the vicinity and I'm
like like oh my and then but if I do
touch it or like brush it or sometimes
it's classic as I'm weed eating and I
just I think I just hit it and just and
it's I don't know it's in the air I walk
through it I'm just like oh no and the
next morning you know my arm and
whatever like you've ever had like a
terrible like a the bad you know the
worst where it's like it keeps you up at
night you're just scr you know but if
you've ever had it that bad you know the
almost like sick pleasure
of just like
I can't freaking take it anymore. You
know what I mean? You just like freak
out and just now this is why the poison
ivy is the absolute devil. It's because
if you scratch it, it 100% feels better,
right? then
and then 60ish seconds later like oh no
oh no it just what you know I mean just
like it's just 10 times worse you know
and I think uh in essence
this is sort of what Paul's kind of
getting at that like he's kind of naming
this is just the way of the world you
know we're all of us are inflicted with
this disease you know we all have this
kind of psychological emotional
you know, suffering and this pain. And
so what do we do? We we act out a lot of
times sexually to kind of um ease to to
try to um deal with it. But um that's
the problem. It like it doesn't solve it
at the root. You know what I mean? It it
eases the pain, but it doesn't like
solve the problem. It doesn't get to the
heart of the matter and kind of heal it
from the inside out. Um now of course
you know sexism isn't our only outlet.
Uh and Paul continues he uses the word
next impurity which for the sake of time
I won't dwell on. I think it ties in
quite closely to his thoughts on kind of
sensuality and such. Um but then he
names a third one. He says uh greed. You
might have caught that word greed. I
would say of the two this is the more
like sort of socially acceptable form of
acting out in essence. Um
there's even movies, you know, greed is
good and sort of the capitalist kind of,
you know, ethos mindset is just like,
hey, get filthy rich and that's like
you're like a success, you know what I
mean? So there's um yeah, this is
uh socially acceptable. But again, see
it through this kind of Dr. Danji's kind
of neurosychological lens. See it
through Paul's eyes, so to speak. And
can you see where greed kind of stems
from again this like unhealthy
relationship to money? In essence, um
it's sort of it's it's using money to um
manage my negative emotions, right? I
think this is sort of gets to the heart
of what greed is actually about. In
other words, you could be like totally
broke and be super greedy,
you know, and you could be really rich
and you may or may not be greedy, you
know, like in essence, it's it's this
relationship to money. Now, granted, I
think there's sort of a line where it's
sort of like, oh, I don't care about
money, even though you like spend your
whole life pursuing it. Okay, so you
know, we'll but let we'll let God judge
the heart of evil, but you can see what
I'm getting at, right? in essence sort
of like sexuality where it's not so much
about oh sex is bad or it's that it's
that emotional relationship to it. I
think money is uh very um similar like
so for example like some of us were
raised in households where money was
scarce you know and so we kind of swore
to ourselves like I'll never be in that
situation again and so anytime we have
that kind of anxious mode that fear mode
we kind of decide like if I can just get
this amount of money then
uh then I'll be, you know, at peace,
then I'll be fine. And you can see where
this starts to shape our emotional
relationship to money. Um or you could
think of it like this. Maybe it's more
um about like status.
Uh you don't have to raise your hand,
but maybe someone can relate to this
where like, you know, I don't feel like
I'm measuring up to that person
uh like from a kind of success
standpoint, you know. But if I got XYZ,
you know, number of dollars, then I
know, you know, like finally I would
feel worthy,
you know, like yes, I would I would
arrive. I think often I heard uh someone
I don't remember remember who it was uh
some speaker was talking about how we're
often chasing like we think we're
chasing a thing, but actually we're
chasing the feeling that we think the
thing will give us.
You know what I mean? And that's where
we get into this weird as we have this
idea of if I could just get to X number
of dollars, then what? Then I'd finally
fill in the blank, you know. And that's
the feeling, the emotional regulation
that we're seeking. Finally, I'd have
peace. Finally, I'd measure up. Finally,
you know, my parents would be proud of
me or, you know, whatever. Like, and and
this is uh where we we get into these,
you know, these modes. And again, you
know, it works sort of. I mean, if it
didn't work, no one would do it. But you
you get to that net worth or whatever
and, you know, it works for like a week
and then you're back to your own
insecurities and struggles and feelings
and uh and which is why we kind of have
to go to the root of it, right? So,
greed's about my emotional relationship
to money, the ways I'm using it to
manage my negative emotions. Uh what I
like about some sort of these framings
is I my hope is to kind of destigmatize
some of this. You know, I think we often
have a hard time talking either noticing
in ourselves these sorts of things or
even speaking to others about them and
certainly in the church, you know,
whether it's our sexual kind of
compulsions, addiction type stuff or,
you know, money and greed and stuff. And
I I hope to kind of frame it in this way
where it can be a little more like, hey,
it's okay. like we're all in this
together. We're all managing our
emotions in like some unhealthy ways.
It's just, you know, pick your poison
like what's your thing? As opposed to I
don't know what their problem is. You
know what I mean? Like, oh, they are
very greedy or something. I think we're
all, you know, kind of muddling through
here. Now, of course, we've kind of
zeroed in on like sexuality and greed um
for this message, but there's like so
many different categories and we could
talk about codependent relationships and
using people to manage our emotions and
even, you know, other substances,
alcohol of course and such and all that.
Um but I think in the end, Paul, what
he's doing here, he's he's inviting us
to more. Verse 18, because they're
darkened in their understanding. They're
separated from the life of God because
of the ignorance that's in them due to
the hardening of their hearts, having
lost all sensitivity.
I think he's pointing out here like what
happens when we engage in these things,
our soul, our our heart, our kind of
emotional center starts to shut down,
right? He says, "The heart grows cold."
Verse 18, "We lose our sensitivity."
Verse 19, "To people and things." Uh
why? Well, because we're using them
instead of like learning to love,
learning to relate. Well, you know,
we're we're we need them in this way
that causes us to kind of use and
potentially abuse them. Paul continues
verse 20. That however is not the way of
life you learned when you heard about
Christ and were taught in him in
accordance with the truth that is in
Jesus. Verse 22. You were taught with
regard to your former way of life to put
off your old self which is being
corrupted by its deceitful desires to be
made new in the attitude of your minds
and to put on the new self created to be
like God in true righteousness and
holiness.
You know, I think this is in many ways
like the good news of Christ. Like it's
the gospel that you can be made new.
Like I think so many of us feel trapped,
you know? We've been in these loops for
like decades, you know, and we just feel
like there's there's no escaping for me,
maybe for other people. It's amazing how
much hope we have for others and how
little we have for ourselves.
But like the truth of the gospel is that
this is true for you.
For you.
Not just everyone else. So it's true for
them too. But for you.
In essence, we've been in these loops
for decades. Chasing chasing sexuality,
chasing greed, chasing success. Oh, that
was a big one for me. Like, oh my god.
To some degree. Still a struggle very
much. just I don't know some mythical
time where I'll arrive and finally feel
worthy you know or I don't even know
what it means but I'm chasing you
chasing chasing chasing chasing people's
approval running running
there's a a famous story it's actually
in the Buddhist scriptures about a uh a
serial killer named Anguli Mala
and he infamously had killed like
hundreds of people. I don't know to what
degree this story is like completely
mythical or has historian whatever. Who
cares? It's a good story. So, Angel, he
famously or infamously had he wore a
necklace and he had one finger from each
of his victims like woven into the
necklace. It's like really gruesome. So,
look, I love the faces. Some of y'all
are like, "This is disgusting story."
Well, that's that's how it goes. So, one
day the Buddha, he's out on his like
daily, you know, walk. In the Buddhist
tradition, the monks go out each morning
midm morning or so to like basically to
beg for their food for the day, you
know, from the local town. So the the
Buddhist he's out and he's uh on his
daily alms round but he takes a takes a
little different direction and he's
going down this path and he's
approaching a forest
and the villagers there let him know
like oh no no no no you don't you know
holy one you don't want to go down like
that path that somewhere in those woods
is anulimala the killer so don't go
there uh but for whatever reason but he
just felt you know prompted like he just
continued
walking down the path when sure enough
out leaps this killer
and he starts in this sort of mad rage.
He's like just tearing after the Buddha
like just running with all his might.
But the strange thing is no matter how
fast he runs, he can never catch up.
And so the Buddha is just there like
just walking and finally he's just
running running and he just yells out to
the Buddha. He's like, "Stop it."
And finally
the Buddha turns around, looks at him,
and says,
"And Gulimala,
it is you who needs to stop, for I have
already stopped. I've already given up
fear and greed and violence. It is you
who needs to stop.
And the tradition holds that immediately
this like struck end like just got to
him and he threw away his his weapons
and he came and he like fell down at the
feet of the saint and that day became a
monk. The the tradition holds that he
actually went on to like really become
like a saint himself. um in that kind of
tradition. And you know, I can't help
but
hear that story. It just reminds me so
much of the narratives we have in the
Gospels. You know, I think of like the
stories about like the the demon
possessed, you know, coming and like
flinging themselves down at the foot of
or the feet of Christ.
And even the story of Paul himself, who
the writer of this book of Ephesians,
who if you know some of his background,
he actually oversaw the murder of the
like the the first Christian martyr,
Stephen. He was like the ring leader of
that, you know, moment. And yet here's
Paul now writing to the Ephesian church
like some 20 years later and speaking, I
think from experience saying like,
"Stop.
Stop.
You You've got to stop avoiding, right?
You can be made new in Christ. Stop.
Stop with the deceitful desires. Stop
with this crazy path you're going down.
And I I think
this is not just some story, you know,
for 2,000 years ago. I think this is as
relevant as ever for us in our
community. In essence, the truth is you
can be made new in Christ. Today can be
a new day for you. But what is needed?
You must stop,
right? You must turn around. Stop
avoiding. Face everything you've been
fearing.
This is what true repentance, to use the
old language, is all about, right? Turn
around. Start going in a new direction.
And what does that mean? It means I
mean, honestly, it's the most freaking
scary thing you'll ever do. Like I think
this is where people get confused about
like well I'm just coming to Jesus, you
know, and they don't maybe realize like
but this is what it means. You know what
I mean? Like it's not just coming
forward and saying like I want to go to
heaven, you know, that's sweet, but the
the the path of disciplehip like this is
it means facing all this crap we just
been talking about, you know, and that's
like really really hard.
But on the other side of it, or I
shouldn't even say on the other side.
you'll arrive. But as we do that, as we
press into that, oh my god, like
suddenly, I mean, this is what Jesus
talked about, right? Like, I've come
that they may have life and have it to
the full. I think we want that. We're
like, yes and amen. We just don't
realize maybe that the the path to that
journey, you know what I mean? This
first step is everything we've been
naming tonight. So, how does it look?
How do we do it? I mean in essence, you
know, it's it's everything we talk about
all the time here, you know, at the
table. This life devoted to Christ, to
the spiritual path. It is a life of
prayer, of of silence. You know what's
the opposite of running, running,
chasing, chasing. I feel emotionally
disregulated and I must solve this
problem right now. You know what's the
opposite of that?
Sitting. I mean it's it's unbelievable
how powerful doing nothing is.
It's it's like the hardest thing, you
know, which is why honestly we'll do
anything but that, you know, that's but
that's the that's the trick of it,
right? It's this life of prayer,
silence, fasting, meditation, meditating
on scripture, community, confession,
living with authenticity, and above all,
learning to love, learning to be
gracious rather than angry, patient
rather than demanding, compassionate
rather than full of judgment. And yes,
it's an arduous path, but friends, it is
a beautiful and gracefilled one at the
same time. And I really do believe if
you'll seek this great healing with all
of your heart,
you will find the peace and the calm
that you've been seeking.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take it. Eat. This is my body broken
for you. And he held up a cup of wine.
He said, "Take it. Drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me.
So as we come forward tonight, we
participate in that mystery. We we take
in Christ. We commune. We connect with
the living God.
Uh the way we'll participate in this is
we'll just go kind of row by row
starting here at the front and we'll
just form one line uh right here in the
middle. So as one row kind of finishes,
the next can, you know, jump up and get
get in line. Uh you should know the red
is wine, the white is grape juice. Uh
we've practiced what's called an open
table. Meaning if you're here tonight
and you'd like to participate, then you
are free to do that. At the same time,
there's no stigma. If you'd rather not,
that's, you know, that's okay. It's just
if there's something in you though that
wants to connect with the risen Christ,
regardless of your, you know, like
theology or whatever, um you're you're
welcome to uh participate and meet us,
meet with us here at this table. Uh so
finally, you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like. Some folks take
right away, others like to kneel. Um
just no one will lead you through the
exact moment of partaking. So this is
the table, not of the church,
but of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come,
come you who have much faith and you who
have little. You have been here often
and you who have not been here long. You
who have tried to follow and you who
have failed, come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
We're going to close with a song called
New Every Morning. Um, if you guys know
it and you would like to stand with us
and sing along, you are more than
welcome to. Um, but I hope that the
words just remind you of Brett's message
tonight, that there is new mercy every
morning. that it's available to us. His
transformational love is here and um we
have access to it. Um and yeah, I hope
that you feel made new tonight.
[Music]
You are not
what you have done
or what has
been done to you.
[Music]
You are something
like the rising sun. Can't you see
you are new?
[Music]
You might have
your father's name
or bear the shame
he left behind.
But there's new life flowing
through your veins. Leave some room to
be surprised.
You are new
every morning.
Each day your resurrection
waiting to break through.
[Music]
You could try
just for a smile
to put the judge
back on the shelf.
All the loving
kindness in your heart. Have a little
more yourself.
You are new
every morning.
Each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
You think hope is lost, but it's just
underground.
That flame might be a number, but the
fire won't go out.
All the evidence is pointing to the
truth.
My daily resurrection is still happening
in you. You are new.
[Music]
Every morning
you are new.
Every morning, each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
You are new.
Oh, we are new.
[Music]
You are new.
Thank you so much for being here with us
this evening. If you are new, we would
love for you to fill out a visitor's
card on the table and you weigh out. We
would love to answer any questions that
you may have and just get a little
information about you.
Generosity is a key aspect here at the
table in the life of adoration and
worship. If if you call the table your
home and this is your community and you
would like to give financially, you can
scan the QR code and find out how to do
that.
If you call the table your home and you
are interested in a meetup, there are
several meetups to choose from. You can
go on to the website and choose one that
fits you the day of the week or the
location.
Um, also likewise, if you do not have a
ministry and you are wanting to do some
kind of a ministry here at the table, we
have several available. You can go
to the website as well. But we have um
our AB, we have our worship team, we
have our host team, we have our kids
ministry,
and just go on and explore and find
something that fits with you.
Don't forget about Hat Creek tonight
after service as a community. We'd love
to see you there. And Jared is our host.
All right. I'd like to send you out with
a benediction.
You may hold your hand out
in a posture to receive
or you just open your hearts to these
words.
You are a child of God.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and this
is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
it yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything that goes in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved and that you are worthy and that
you're accepted
just as you are. And go filled with
God's the Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone that you
come in contact with.
Be blessed.
Have a great week and we hope to see you
back here next Sunday or at Hat Creek.
Thank you.
[Music]
But it's just underground.
That flame might be a number, but the
fire won't go out.
All the evidence is pointing to the
truth. That daily resurrection is still
happening in you. You are new.
Every morning
you are new.
Every morning each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
You are new.
Oh,
you are new.
[Music]